there is by my calculation
not a single thing less appealing than
listening to a hollywood actress
complain to a billionaire talk show host
about how hard it was to be
a princess i that is
the actual mathematical perfectly least
likable thing that i think anyone could
possibly do
meghan markle sits down with her poor
poor husband and talks to oprah
about all the dirty laundry
from the royal family there was no
guidance as well right there were
certain things that you couldn't do but
you know unlike what you see in the
movies there's no class on how to
how to speak how to cross your legs how
to be
royal there's none of that trend that
might exist for other members
of the family that was not something
that was offered to me so nobody tells
you anything
no nobody prepares you no i mean no but
even sorry but even down to like the
national anthem
no one thought to say oh you're american
you're not gonna know that that's me
late at night googling
how what's the i've got to learn this i
don't want to embarrass them i need to
learn these
30 hymns for church all of this is
televised we were doing the training
behind the scenes because i just wanted
to make them proud
i just i just wanted to make them proud
and that is why
i'm sitting down with you oprah to say
that these are the worst people on earth
because i'm just
i just care and i want to make them pred
it's just you know it's crazy
all i wanted to do all i wanted to do as
a
divorced american actress was become
a princess in another country and they
expect me to learn the national anthem
uh what is that crazy what what do they
think i have google
what do they what do they think that i
can like look it up that's crazy
i need well actually you know it shut up
shut up harry
stop it it's just ridiculous
you know i you see am a victim
says the princess so
president trump as always summed this up
a couple of years ago he was asked about
some criticism that meghan markle had
made of him
she was not at that time attacking the
con the government and the royalty of
her adopted
country she was attacking her own
government
and president trump i thought had the
most compassionate
and precise take on meghan markle that
one can muster
prince harry and meghan markle uh chimed
in on the us election and essentially
encouraged people to vote for joe biden
let me get your reaction to that i'm not
a fan of hers
and i would say this
and she probably has heard that but
i wish a lot of luck to harry
because he's going to need it
he's gonna need it that poor guy does
need it this
woman comes in
the reason i mention by the way that
she's divorced is
she is entering into the royal family of
a country with a state church
so it's actually a big problem and
rather than say oh my gosh thank you for
making this exception i know
this is bad i know it's we shouldn't we
shouldn't be doing this here in the
royal family
instead she complains about having to
learn hymns
but they expect me to learn the hymns
because i'm entering into the family
that runs the state church come on
give me a break poor
poor harry so because she doesn't like
it because it turns out that being a
royal
is not just about glitz and glamour and
putting a tiara on because
she found out it actually involves duty
and work you know
very difficult sort of chores like
learning the national anthem of your
country
of your new country because of that she
made her husband leave his family
and abdicate all of his duty all of his
responsibility to the country that had
been so good to him and that he was born
for like no we got to go because i want
to do voice-overs in disney cartoons or
something
so they leave now they're in la they get
to keep a lot of money
and poor harry is just struggling
through
now they're attacking his family on
television and the minute he tries to
interject she tells him to keep quiet
but then she talks about real struggles
and this i actually
i don't want to make light of this i
just want to show how perverse our
thinking of this is
as meghan markle says this was so
tough to be a princess that i
contemplated suicide and
she very well may have people in
hollywood are unstable people
generally speaking and maybe she just
couldn't take it maybe she
did not she had a completely different
vision of what it meant to be a royal
maybe she thought it was all about
privilege and not at all about duty and
responsibility
so she was genuinely shocked and she
just couldn't handle it
we had to go to this event and i
remember him saying i don't think you
can go and i said i can't be left alone
because you were afraid of what you
might do to yourself
and we went and that's so sorry to hear
that
and that picture if you zoom in what i
see is how tightly his
knuckles are gripped around mine you can
see the whites of our knuckles because
we are smiling and doing our job
but we're both just trying to hold on
and every time that those lights went
down in that royal box
i was just weeping and he was gripping
my hand and then it was
okay intermission's coming it takes so
much courage to admit that you need help
it takes so much courage to voice that
so
before i criticize what she has to say
here
there is truth to this it does take
courage
to admit when you need help
this is part of the process of
recognizing our own brokenness
in in our human nature right this is
this is a central fact of a christian
life
is having the courage to recognize you
are not perfect that you need
help that you are a miserable sinner and
that you
cannot fix your brokenness on your own
right it's actually
a keen insight and unfortunately in our
now secularized culture
a lot of people don't understand that
and so they're not willing to get help
and that's that's why there actually is
some legitimately legitimacy to this
idea that we need to
reach out we need to you know muster the
courage to recognize our own inner
problems
sure all true
whether or not going on oprah winfrey's
show
to whine about your husband's family
that you made him
essentially divorce whether that is
helpful to your inner struggle
seems a little dubious to me but the
principle fair enough
there's a flip side though to all this
talk about the courage
to muster the strength to just think
about yourself all the time
the flip side of that is it also takes
courage
to do your duty it also takes courage
to fulfill your responsibilities
to other people and not just yourself
when you marry into the royal family
it's not as though
you know on the fifth date or something
harry sets megan down and says you know
you know love you know the problem i
love
i have something to admit to you i'm a
prince of
england what harry yes i dare you i know
you thought i was a
a motorcycle mechanic but actually i'm a
prince
oh my gosh well we'll make it through
harry well i hope that we can survive
this because i love you
and i had no idea that you were a prince
now i think she knew from the beginning
she just was it would seem only focused
on
the glitz and the glamour and the
privilege of it all but it is a weighty
weighty responsibility
i think too many of our elites forget
meghan markle for a second too many of
our elites don't understand this
they think when you become prominent in
i don't know politics or the media
or this that or the other thing it's
just all about privilege
it's just all about glitz and glamour
they don't want to recognize the duty
and the responsibility
and the gravity and the weight of that
if you forget about being a royal where
your entire life
is duty it's why i can't get on board
with the
the kind of conservative american hatred
for the royals you know
all the jokes about the royals well they
live in palaces they have fancy clothing
the the royals lives are very difficult
from the moment they are born their
entire life
is just about serving the country and
doing whatever the country needs them to
do
and it might seem kind of frivolous
because it's photo ops and it's opening
up different markets and
things like that and welcoming foreign
dignitaries but you
are born into a very specific job with a
ton of media scrutiny
and you can never change it unless you
abdicate
like harry because he met this
american wife unless you abdicate and
bring shame on yourself
you just have to do that job most of us
don't even want to do
the job that we chose for our entire
lives a lot of people they start doing a
job they're like i kind of want to do
something else maybe they start doing
something else
within the broader industry maybe they
switch careers right you don't get to
switch careers
if you're a royal you don't get to just
do whatever you want all the time you
have to focus on that responsibility
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts